i don't live in a hole so you know what
you know certainly the consequences of
winning and losing are uh but
again i've had fun all year playing i i
really have and
yeah it's maybe a few more people care
about the game you know now that now
that quote unquote means something but i
i don't think it changes anything for
this team
he's such a lovable weirdo he really is
it's amazing when you hear his voice
nearest mother the titans are coming to
town dearest mother
i keep waiting for him wouldn't it be
great i mean it would be the ultimate
exercise in self-awareness if he would
work dearest mother
into one of his
his uh press conferences or media
availability it would be i mean he just
uh if anybody out there just meeting him
a few times they they don't come any
nicer than andrew luck uh you could just
tell the kind of professionally his
weekend week out he never points fingers
i do respect his game and he's back in
the conversation as one of the five best
quarterbacks in football i think he's
proven that to us this year with what
he's done you know now has an offensive
line it's been a pretty special year so
i've enjoyed that as far as andrew
luck's concerned
is lovable weirdo a fair description i
think i
yeah it's yeah it's it's weirdo in a
nice way i know what you mean i mean
he's got that you know all shucks laugh
oh more people are going to be watching
this weekend ha ha you know yeah i get
it i got what you're saying
and and he's different from i mean
that's one of the reasons i like you
there aren't many
but one of the reasons i like you is
you're so different than what i expected
because there's that quarterback
mentality that kind of uh a jerk kind of
a butthole kind of a you know
over-the-top ego kind of a thing that
you expect a quarterback to have because
you need that in order to thrive and it
may explain why you didn't thrive but
it's a good personality trait and you
kind of have that in common with with
andrew like i guess what i'm saying is
you're a lovable weirdo too but i don't
mean it in the same vein no you do you
yeah you like it it's okay don't worry
just embrace it it's the holidays it's
okay to show a little love to me it's
all right you're good and and here's the
thing a year after the indianapolis
colts didn't have the services of andrew
luck for the entire season they have him
for week 17 in a playoff play in game
and the real question is will the titans
have their starting quarterback marcus
mariota has a stinger you know and it it
happened the exact same way in the
regular season looked like an elbow
injury it's a stinger half of his body
goes numb
and marcus mariota doesn't know whether
or not he's going to be able to play on
sunday and that that is a huge
difference when you go from
mario to blaine gabbard that potentially
impacts whether or not you're going to
manage a victory at home against the
colts and for the titans chris this
dawned on us i think mds figured this
out on tuesday
the idea that the titans could go from
out of the playoffs all the way up to
the two seed depending upon how the day
shakes out they could get a bye and
they'll know by the time the game starts
everything else will be done we'll know
exactly what's on the line we already
know that a playoff berth is on the line
the loser's out the winner's in but the
winner could go if it's tennessee all
the way to the number two seed it's a
potentially fascinating uh uh
array of developments that could all
play out throughout the course of the
day yeah i mean it really is it's
fascinating to think that the tennessee
titans could be the number two seed uh i
am of course excited for that football
game in general i'll say this much i i
don't the titans are a team i'm sorry
tennessee i don't mean to be a jerk or
anything like that i don't want to see
him in the playoffs i really don't i'm
confident you're being a jerk joining
the bluff
stats has been saying that too i like
the titans thank you chris i don't sorry
i'm on team stats on this one i just i
look at this the titans and i think this
everywhere they go people want to know
who they are
so we do tell them they're the mighty
mighty titans but the the thing that i
think bothers me more than anything
about them and listen there's qualities
about their team i do like and i respect
their coaching staff i really respect
where they're going as an organization
what i what i don't like about them this
year as a team is i don't really think
there's anything elite about their
football team not one unit not one
player they got a lot of good a lot of
solid but as we saw last week on
saturday night against the washington
redskins i mean
they could their defense couldn't get
off the field on josh johnson which was
you know kind of embarrassing at times
since josh johnson you know has only
started like one game in his life and
that was a long long time ago uh yes i
look i don't look at the elite factor
with the tennessee titans i think that
bothers me where i can look at the colts
and go you know there's of course the
things that admire but there's two elite
things they got on their football team
one they're offensive line right mike
they're it's as elite as it gets and
then their quarterbacks elite and i
think because of that i think they're
dangerous in the playoffs where i look
at tennessee and i go uh if they get in
i mean i just don't care i don't think
they have any chance of making a serious
run and i know i'm disrespecting the
tennessee titans here but i'm sorry i'm
just giving my honest thoughts
well they've managed to win four in a
row they were so inconsistent earlier in
the year and they wouldn't even be in
this spot if they had been more
consistent when they had played well if
they could have continued it for a few
more weeks they'd already have it nailed
down and they would be legitimately
competing for the one seed or the two
seed at this point i agree with you
there's something missing but that's
what makes it even more fascinating the
fact that that mike vrabel the coach of
the team in his first year is kind of
willing this team to be better than the
sum of its parts especially with blaine
gabbert coming in and winning the game
on saturday night to keep the titans
hopes alive and and i i don't know how i
feel about this game but i do like the
idea that we have a playoff play in game
on sunday night football and the stakes
may be a lot higher than the sixth seed
we'll know by the time we get there
whether or not they are playing for the
sixth spot and a trip to face the three
seed which most likely will be the
houston texans another afc south
showdown in the postseason or or whether
or not they they win the division if the
texans lose to the jaguars the winner of
that game on sunday night will win the
afc south and have a home playoff game
right out of the gates and possibly get
a bye if it's the titans and enough
other things happen now with the ravens
and the steelers one is getting in and
one is not getting in one will be the
afc north champion and one will be out
of the playoffs altogether and for
baltimore it's simple and i was saying
this last hour chris you may have heard
me say it if the ravens can't beat the
browns who are playing for nothing
and the ravens are playing for
everything they don't deserve to be in
the playoffs yeah you can't beat a team
that is not in the mix to get into the
post-season that they're already done
that it's already over if you can't win
that game then you don't deserve it and
uh so it's it's that simple ravens what
can you do against the browns team is
going to be very motivated even though
they're not playing for a playoff berth
they're convinced this is their bowl
game and they want to come to baltimore
and knock the ravens out of the playoffs
yeah i think that's the point right
there you know that that's why they're
kind of a you know a little bit of a
under the radar sleeper here the
cleveland browns or a sleeping giant per
se because yes there is no pressure but
yet at the same time they do kind of
want to end their season off on a
positive note they got some you know
positive vibe the mojo going into
cleveland their defenses played very
good down the stretch we've seen the run
game and baker mayfield
really be impressive nick chubb and
baker mayfield two rookies in the
backfield who
couldn't be any more impressive they
have the offensive line mike to kind of
slow down the baltimore ravens defensive
line and not get steamrolled there uh i
i i again i sit here and i go i favor
the ravens you and i both know the
ravens their play
it's going to make the game close no
matter what that's the way they play
they want to play defense run the
football and i look at the browns as a
team with not a lot of pressure but yet
still wanting to win and continue those
positive vibes like you're saying and i
go ooh watch out this is dangerous it
really is i mean it's a one it's gonna
be a one score football game even if the
ravens dominate the football game and i
think balto i mean i think cleveland
matches up pretty well with baltimore
and one strip sack fumble or one
turnover and that game can change i
really do give cleveland a chance in
this one i think they could make some
waves and at least uh give give
baltimore a really tough time
and here's one way the browns can be
very dangerous they they literally have
nothing to lose because they have
nothing to gain right this is it this is
their last game so they can throw
anything they want at the ravens they
can take risks because there's no
downside when oh okay we lost the game
and our season's over it was going to be
over anyway we'll lose the season's over
now i wonder whether or not greg
williams believes that this is the game
that becomes the closing argument for
him to be the next coach of the browns i
i hope look and look and i
i choose my words carefully here well
maybe not i hope the browns don't hire
greg williams to be their coach because
i think they can do so much better with
baker mayfield with this buzz that
they've built whether they finish 8-7-1
or 7-8-1 they're going to be able to get
they're going to be able to lure a much
better head coach than greg williams you
know somebody suggested the other day
that if the browns don't make greg
williams the head coach someone else is
going to hire him no they're not they're
not
and i think the browns need to recognize
that they could be a super bowl team
next year if they hire the right coach
and i just don't believe the right coach
is greg williams no i i would agree with
you there i don't look at him as being
the future of the cleveland browns or
the guy to lead them you know to the
promised land one day i do look at him
as still a really good defensive mind
and wouldn't be shocked if an offensive
head coach went in there and kept greg
williams on the defensive side and kept
that staff intact uh wait a minute
though i know
how awkward would that be yes it would
be it's almost like williams has done so
well that he can't stay in any capacity
other than head coach yeah well it's
gonna you're right i mean it's gonna
have to be a strong head coach who can
ask the personality to take that but
you're right now that he's had that
success it will it'll make that a little
harder because if you go on a losing
streak with the new head coach and greg
williams is still in the building
they're gonna go man man we might have
been better off with that guy so i think
that's the the problem that exists there
and that's probably why he doesn't end
up there i'm just throwing it out there
either way but either way he doesn't
know whether he's getting the job or not
right mike right now he thinks there's a
chance and he's gonna have his team
ready to play and i think to your point
yeah maybe we see
flea flickers or a fake pun on fourth
and three something like that because
there is nothing to lose uh they're
young they're kind of you know what do
they say green between the ears right
now they don't even know the environment
they're going into they just i've never
heard that no okay maybe between the
ears yeah they're wet behind the ears i
think that's the one i was looking for
good job there you go that was the one i
was looking how do you confuse green
with wet i don't know i think there was
something there what do i want dog i'll
come up with it later there's something
about green if you're green
a green horn there's a green horn there
we go see i like to combine things to
make them hit home every now and then i
see just it was a double whammy it hit
hard there but uh getting back to my
point which i don't even know what it
was at this point no but yeah that makes
too much wet behind the ears is what i'm
saying and they don't even know the
pressure that they're going into they
don't care they just want to play
football baker mayfield doesn't give a
damn whether he's staring down a head
coach or playing the ravens whatever it
may be
he's going to go out there and give his
best effort and i'm excited to watch
them play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports